Democratic congressman Eric's whoa well
broadcasts hot air on MSNBC but not so
much hot air as Democratic Senator Chris
Murphy or House Speaker Nancy Pelosi we
will examine these shameless gas bagger
II of our leaders then across the pond
the UK's Prince Andrew sweats over
questions about his relationship with
Jeffrey Epstein who didn't kill himself
a New Zealand hunter gets death threats
for killing her own food and
conservatives favorite chicken
restaurant gives in to the leftist mob
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
some people are just catching wind of
Eric's whoa Wells appearance on MSNBC
last night but a whistleblower showed
that Eric's wall well past gas on live
television
sOooo well himself has been gas lighting
on the subject and insisting that it
never happened but something about his
denial just doesn't smell right listen
for yourself the evidence is
uncontradicted that the president used
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help him cheat an election now that I
know it's sometimes it's hard to figure
out when it's just eric's well-well
talking and when he literally passed gas
on television sometimes it's very
confusing it would appear to me that he
did in fact break wind on national
television this is trending on twitter
as hashtag fort gate I'm sorry that I
even have to say that publicly but it
was the top trend on Twitter for many
many hours yesterday I loved Eric's wall
well I just love him so much I don't
really have very much to say about the
incident itself it's very very very
unfortunate it's probably the worst
thing I could possibly imagine having
happen if you're on national television
but one of the keys to Eric's wall well
is that he feels no shame one of the key
defining characters of Eric's wall well
is he is just completely oblivious to
his own absurdity so he does this and
you could all hear it and then Eric's
wall well comes back and says no that
wasn't me I don't know who it was it
obviously was by the way if you just
look at the clip he becomes physically
uncomfortable during it so it would
appear that it was Eric's wall well but
you know he just keeps trucking on
truckin on and what is really incredible
is that that clip literally breaking
wind was not the most absurd thing that
Eric's wall well did on television all
day Eric's whoa whoa well then goes back
on television
he's on CNN and he insists with a
straight face that President Trump needs
to be thrown out of office because he
conspired with a foreign power to steal
the 2016 election here he is
but the House Speaker seems to have
already made up her mind about
impeaching the president let's say you I
have not and I don't think she has
either but the evidence points in one
direction that this president leveraged
our taxpayer dollars to have the
Ukrainians help him cheat an election
and he has had every opportunity to send
in witnesses that would show his
innocence and he has blocked those
witnesses from coming forward and so we
can only conclude that that's where the
evidence is going to early to reach an
ultimate conclusion wolf but the
president has an opportunity to send
over the witnesses we've asked for is
that so Erick's whoa well you Erick's
well well a Democrat a member of a party
that purchased foreign intelligence from
an operative team fusion GPS during the
2016 election you went in paid off
former journalists to work with a
foreign intelligence officer to dig up
dirt on Donald Trump you then used the
power of the state illegally to spy on
the opponent's campaign you actually
colluded to try to steal the 2016
election you were going to accuse
president Trump of doing that very same
thing that's what they're doing the left
always does this by the way he let the
left always accuses the right of doing
what the left is doing and swoll wall
can say that with a straight face
frankly I feel it's less absurd to break
wind on television with a straight face
than it is to expel that ridiculous hot
air from his mouth for for Erick's well
want to go out there and say the
president can exonerate himself he just
needs to let people testify Democrats
have called three key witnesses already
they called Bill Taylor remember that a
few days ago the ambassador they called
George Kent the Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State they called Murray
ivanovitch the ambassador to Ukraine all
three of these people were supposed to
be the bombshell testimony remember that
and then Bill Taylor said he had no
evidence of a quid pro quo
George Kent said it was perfectly
legitimate for
Trump tasks for an investigation into
Ukrainian corruption in 2016 and Murray
Ivanovich was asked point-blank do you
have any evidence that the president
committed any sort of crime and she said
no no I don't she said it twice in a row
and Eric's wall wall goes on TV and says
the president is stealing the election
he's committing collusion and we need to
throw him out of office for that four
times now in this country
impeachment has been invoked Andrew
Johnson Richard Nixon who resigned
before he could be impeached
Bill Clinton now Donald Trump the this
fourth impeachment Donald Trump by far
the least legitimate by far there is so
little evidence of any sort of crime and
swall well goes on TV and insists that
we need to throw him out of office for
it and even swallow wasn't the most
ridiculous person here Chris Murphy a
Democrat in the Senate went on
television and instead of just hitting
Trump for the Ukraine non traversée he's
defending the Biden's who are actually
the subject of the non traversée because
of the corruption they engaged in in
Ukraine which prompted the call for an
investigation which prompted the
impeachment in the first place here's
Senator Chris Murphy I get that in your
view what's going on right now with
President Trump is a much much bigger
deal and much more important than the
hunter Biden situation but just
point-blank should hunter Biden have
taken that role on the board of Burr
yzma while his dad was vice president
well I think in an interview hundred
Biden himself admitted that you know he
had possibly made a mistake but let's be
clear hunter Biden didn't do anything
illegal and his father the vice
president didn't do anything illegal or
unethical and all of these attacks on
the Biden's and the effort to bring the
whistleblower in to testify are just an
attempt to try to put more Chum in the
water and distract from the corrupt
scheme that is at the heart of this
inquiry the Biden's are totally innocent
the Bynes the Biden corruption that's
not even an important story here when
we're talking about how President Trump
was trying to investigate Biden's
corruption we'll get to this nonsense in
a second first I've got to think
friends over at NetSuite it is very
important for growing businesses to know
their numbers have worked at a lot of
companies that have just been getting
off the ground including the daily wire
the problem that growing businesses have
that keeps them from growing is knowing
their numbers and how do you have
trouble knowing your numbers that's when
you've got this hodgepodge of business
systems this is where NetSuite comes in
very handy introducing NetSuite by
Oracle the business management software
that handles every single aspect of your
business in an easy-to-use cloud
platform gives you the visibility and
the control you need to grow so very
often what happens I've seen it
firsthand businesses just start out and
they're using whatever software whatever
systems they're comfortable with or
easiest or they just use that of
convenience and then those systems don't
talk to one another so you end up
wasting a lot of time and a lot of money
you get a lot of unneeded headaches and
by the way time is money and those
unneeded headaches cost you time and
money so they're what they're trying to
do is they're trying to keep track of
sales and finance and this and that make
it they're not speaking to each other
right now you can save yourself all that
hassle with NetSuite and that suite
manages sales finance accounting orders
HR instantly right from your desktop or
your phone that's why NetSuite is the
world's number one cloud business system
don't handicap your business go use the
very best you'll save a lot of time and
a lot of money you will be so thankful
in the end right now NetSuite is
offering you valuable insights with a
free guide seven key strategies to grow
your profits that's at NetSuite calm
sloshing Knowles canna wles NetSuite
dot-com slash Knowles Canada wles
go over there right now download your
free guide no reason not to take this
excellent advice seven key strategies to
grow your profits
NetSuite dot-com slash Knowles Canada
wles so Democratic Senator Chris Murphy
goes on television he says Joe Biden
hunter Biden they did nothing wrong
now of course we know they did something
wrong here because hunter Biden came out
and said that he was sorry that he did
it and he he got off of the board he
resigned from the board of the Ukrainian
energy company burries moe
like saying hey look I did nothing wrong
I'm completely right I'm totally
exonerated and by the way I'll never do
it again very sorry of course he did
something wrong Joe Biden knows that he
did something wrong which is why when
Joe Biden found out that hunter Biden
was on the board of Purisima he said to
him you better know what you're doing
that's according to a magazine interview
that hunter Biden gave in July that's
according to TV interviews under Biden
gave just a month or two ago Biden knew
there was something very very fishy here
Biden said in his administration he's
not going to allow this kind of nepotism
and corruption well if he's not going to
allow it for the president why was it
okay when he was the vice president
simply doesn't add up obviously this was
pretty crooked him by the way we're only
talking about Ukraine right now he did
the same thing in China hunter Biden
flew on Air Force two with then Vice
President Joe Biden goes to this meeting
in China and then just coincidentally
not long after that winds up with a
billion and a half dollars worth of
financing out of China so obviously
there's a lot of corruption going on
here and Chris Murphy says don't talk
about that corruption talk about the
impeachment what I have said from the
very beginning as impeachment is not
going to look good for Democrats
especially not gonna look good for Joe
Biden because in order to talk about
impeachment you have to talk about
Biden's corruption that's what their
impeaching him over is he had a phone
call with Ukraine President Trump and
and Trump said hey by the way look into
that corruption in Ukraine and look into
the interference in the 2016 election so
he's allowed he's not allowed to do that
but Democrats are allowed to spend two
and a half years investigating Russian
collusion which totally exonerated the
president and by the way Democrats were
allowed to get off scot-free
when they themselves interfered and
bought off foreign intelligence in the
2016 election now I'm actually not sure
they're gonna get off scot-free we're
obviously waiting for the IG report in
the John
durum investigation into how the whole
Russia hoax came to be in the first
place and maybe which Obama
administration officials and Democrats
and and Foreign Assets are culpable in
the attempt to rig the 2016 election and
the now
known in demonstrable spying on the
Trump campaign so what I actually think
is that this impeachment push is an
early defensive measure to mitigate
whatever comes out in that investigation
in 2016 but regardless absolutely
shameless and then Nancy Pelosi the most
shameless one of all comes and puts the
little cherry on top of the sundae she
wants President Trump to testify does
the president get as he says to confront
his accuser or get dubious in France his
accuser confront the whistleblower
presumably I mean make sure he does not
intimidate the whistleblower I was there
I told the president you're in my
wheelhouse when you come after the
whistleblower this is really important
especially when it comes to intelligence
that someone who would be courageous
enough to point out truth to power and
then through the filter of a from
appointed Inspector General who found it
of urgent concern and and and then took
it to the next steps so the president
could come back before the committee and
talk speak all the truth that he wants
if he doesn't expect him if he wants to
take the oath of office or he could do
it writing he has every opportunity to
present his case but it's really a sad
thing I mean what the President did was
so much worse than even what Richard
Nixon did but at some point Richard
Nixon cared about the country enough to
recognize that this could not continue
allow me to translate that for you Nancy
Pelosi is saying that what Trump did is
so much worse than what Richard Nixon
did by the way what Nixon did was his
goons didn't know how to tape a door
this is how the fall of Richard Nixon
came because the two burglars who broke
into Watergate should have taped the
door up to down to keep the door open
once they were stealing the documents
out of Watergate but instead they taped
it side to side so a security guard was
able to see it and so these burglars
engaged in a dirty trick which Richard
Nixon by all accounts didn't know
anything about by the way and then he
covered it up and then they threw him
out why did they really throw him out
they wanted to overturn
the presidential election because they
were furious that Nixon won in the first
place they were certainly furious that
he got reelected they stole the election
from him in 1960 successfully and they
never forgave the guy for following
Alger Hiss who is a leftist darling at
the State Department who was a communist
spy and he was called out as a communist
spy by Whittaker Chambers and Richard
Nixon was the only one who believed him
and went and got him and the left never
forgave him for it that is the
background that very few people talk
about when you talk about the Richard
Nixon impeachment but what Pelosi is
saying is what Trump did is so much
worse than that
let me ask you a question Nancy Pelosi
what did Trump do because the storyline
now has changed about a million times
not even just from the Russia hoax to
stormy Daniels to taxes to now Ukraine
but even within Ukraine what did he do
you saying it was bribery you're saying
it was a quid pro quo you're saying it
was an abuse of power so maybe it wasn't
a crime what are you talking about if if
Nancy Pelosi were telling the truth if
what Trump did with regard to Ukraine
was worse than what Richard Nixon did
it's an impeachable offense then Nancy
Pelosi would state the offense this is
how you know the Democrats are full of
hot air here is they can't even state
with the offenses I can't even stay with
the offenses I followed this story every
single day but the storyline changes
every day because all the witnesses that
the Democrats are calling to testify say
the Trump did nothing wrong you've got
bill Taylor George Ken Murray Ivanovitch
who else are they gonna get to say the
Trump committed an impeachable offense
nobody so disingenuous so totally
disingenuous but if you want the height
of gas bagger II you actually can't even
stay in America you gotta cross the pond
and head over to the UK where Prince
Andrew good buddies with Jeffrey Epstein
who definitely didn't kill himself is
now trying to defend his relationship
with the possibly dead disgraced
pedophile in a way that it made me blush
how shameless it was we'll get to that
in a second
then we'll get to so very much more but
first I've got to thank our friends over
at ancestry.com
I have been a fan of ancestry since long
before I had this show since before the
daily wire existed ancestry has
incredible tools obviously they have
their family trees and their research
technology then they've got the DNA kit
where you spit into the tube and now
they can tell you so much more so your
genes are not just about you your genes
are something that you share with the
people closest to you and now with
ancestry it's not just that you can get
incredible insights about your family
history and how your ancestors moved
around and and so much about your own
genetic makeup but now you can uncover
potential health issues early that can
help empower you with information so you
and your family can move forward toward
a healthier future I've been waiting for
a long time for this product to come out
from ancestry they wanted to wait to
make sure they got it perfect and they
have ancestry health you know some
health conditions can be influenced by
genetics ancestry health looks at a
carefully selected set and gives you
insights about how they could impact you
and your health and your family ancestry
health gives you personalized health
reports that are easy to understand with
actionable insights this is the key here
they give you information that you can
actually act upon they're not just going
to tell you things that are completely
irrelevant cuz you can't do anything
about it you get access to genetic
counseling resources family health
history tool to track generations of
health and of course you'll also receive
ancestry dnase ethnicity results they're
reveal your origins I just got an update
on mine the other day it's super cool I
love ancestry it's just a tremendous
product and I'm just so glad they've
added this product and I'm glad that
they've waited long enough to really
perfect it learn from your genes and
take action for your family go to
ancestry.com slash Knowles Canada wles
to learn more get your ancestry health
kit today ancestry.com / Knowles cannon
wles I love these guys ancestry health
includes laboratory tests developed and
performed by an independent CLIA
certified laboratory partner with an
oversight from an independent clinician
network of board-certified physicians
and genetic counselors ancestry health
is not currently available in New York
New Jersey or Road Isle
but everywhere else go check it out it's
a great great product you want the
relight of gas bagger e you actually
can't just stick around with Erics whoa
well in Chris Murphy and Nancy Pelosi
you got to go to the United Kingdom you
got to go to Prince Andrew son of Queen
Elizabeth who was friends with Jeffrey
Epstein and took a lot of photos with
Jeffrey Epstein and has allegations that
he slept with some of Epstein's girls
he's finally answering questions about
this Jeffrey Epstein thought or rather
Prince Andrew thought that the best way
to get in front of this story was to go
and do a television interview this
became one of the biggest PR disasters
in recent royal memory and it shows you
if you're not a good BSR like for
instance Nancy Pelosi or Erik's whoa
well don't go on television and try to
lie to the entire world because it looks
really dishonest he got caught in a
couple lies here here is Prince Andrew
asked about his old pal Jeffrey Epstein
what does he have to say he has quite
obviously conducted himself in a manner
unbecoming
yes I'm becoming he was a sex offender
yeah I'm sorry I'm being polite up in
the sense that he was a sex offender oh
not a great start
Prince Andrew now in Prince Andrew's
defense I don't like using ugly words in
public I don't like it I don't like
using swear words in public I don't even
like mentioning what Eric's well well
did on national television it's just
that itself is unbecoming however I'm
not sure that's exactly what Prince
Andrew is doing here I don't think it's
simply because of the dignity of his
role and his office that he's not using
this line I think it's because he
doesn't want to admit that his friend of
many years who he hung out with even
pretty recently was one of the most
notorious sex offenders in histories
well you know what you did there was
something a little bit unbecoming you
mean that he was a notorious sex abuser
and child sex trafficker yes that's what
I meant then the interviewer gets down
to brass tacks asks Prince Andrew
about sleeping with Epstein's Hyrum for
the record is there any way you could
have had sex with that young woman or
any young woman trafficked by Jeffrey
Epstein in any of his residences no and
and and without putting too fine a point
on it if you're a man it is a positive
act to have sex with somebody you have
to have to take some sort of positive
action and so therefore if you try to
forget it's very difficult to try and
forget positive action and I do not
remember anything I can't I've racked my
brain I'm thinking oh well when the
first allegation is when the allegations
came out originally I went well that's a
bit strange I don't remember this and
then I've been through it and through it
and through it over and over and over
again and no nothing no no nothing I
don't I don't think I don't believe that
I remember that if I were to have slept
with the girls I would have had to put
my little mini royal into the end I
don't believe if I say I'm scratching my
head and it's just not coming up then
very bad excuse you could just say no
you just say didn't happen
yeah if it didn't happen then you come
and say nope didn't happen if you want
to leave yourself a leeway then you need
to pretend like you might not remember
look I don't have a great memory either
okay and Prince Andrew has been seen out
partying and he's had a bit of a
colorful life so I could understand if
your long-term memory is a little hazy
if you regularly frequent the private
residences and islands of the world's
most notorious sex trafficker filled
with young and underage girls I think
you would remember that I think you
would remember whether you slept with
any of them or not I don't think it
would be confusing I don't think you'd
have to Rack your mind as I did I did I
accidentally trip
rock on little st. James Island perhaps
full-on drop of why you wouldn't do that
you would just you either did it or you
didn't do it the fact that he's now
backtracking and he used to deny these
allegations everything you can't
remember not a great look
then the interviewer keeps pressing and
the interviewer keeps going off the
rails and so does Prince Andrew cop do
it no he puts out even more hot air we
will get to that in a second when
presenter is asked why he stated
Epstein's house after Epstein was
convicted for child sex crimes
we will then of course get to
chick-fil-a just after Kanye West
memorializes chick-fil-a's wonderful
Christian values in a rap song
chick-fil-a
totally gives in to the radical left we
will get to that we will get to the
left's fury that a hunter killed her own
food and the consequences of ecological
sin but first I have got to thank our
friends over at quip you can see my
pearly whites what do you what do you
know about those it's very important to
have nice clean white teeth and there
are fewer healthy habits that are more
important than regularly brushing your
teeth that's where quip makers of the
quip electronic toothbrush comes in
quips electric brush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean makes it so easy to stick to
a healthy brushing habit starting with
an electric toothbrush refillable floss
and anti cavity toothpaste I really like
quit because it's very slick you can put
it in your travel kit it's not like a
giant bazooka cannon I used to brush
with just a regular toothbrush it's
basically like brushing with a stick
like I was a caveman and your teeth just
get yellow especially if you like me
where all you drink is coffee and tea
and booze and smoke cigars so you've got
to be able to brush your teeth regularly
having an electronic toothbrush is just
so much better I can't even fathom now
going back quip makes it slick easy they
time it for you that take all the
guesswork out and by the way quip
delivers fresh brush heads floss and
toothpaste refills to your door every
three months with free shipping you
don't have to worry about it
is always right and you're not gonna be
trying to squeeze that last cubic
millimeter out of the toothpaste tube to
try to press your teeth for three weeks
join over 3 million healthy mouth and
get quip today starting at $25 if you go
to get quip dot-com slash michael mi CH
AE L right now you'll get your first
refill for free that is your first
refill free at get quip calm slash
michael mi CH AE l GE t qu IP comm slash
michael mi CH AE l quip the good habits
company we have got to get to well the
rest of Prince Andrew because it shows
you a lot about our own leaders too then
we've got chick-fil-a then we've got the
moral incoherence and idiocy over
hunters and the bizarre term ecological
sin which we're now hearing from people
around the Pope but first we've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube in
honor of the truly hilarious self owned
by Liz Warren Lea witha Foca hunters
tweeting and saying that she's selling a
billionaire tears mug on Shopify that
will actually enrich the Shopify
billionaire founder Toby looky here at
the daily wire we are offering 20% off
on our all-access and insider plus
subscriptions when you use the promo
code Warren tears warren tears you could
save heap big wampum with insider plus
and all-access you can get the
incredible leftist tears hot or cold
tumbler today is the last day to join so
again as the last day is today promo
code Warren at tears for 20% off your
subscription come join the fun you get
look you get so much when you join the
daily wire me the Andrew Clavin show the
ben shapiro show the matt walsh so you
get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up on thursday you have to ask
questions backstage you get another
kingdom the third and final season and
you get that left as tears tumblr daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
okay so you've got a master class in gas
bagger II from Prince Andrew a master
class and how not to comport yourself in
public first Prince Andrews asked about
his old friend Jeffrey Epstein
he says it's unbecoming to have sex with
children then he's asked whether or not
he sleeps with the young girls and he
says well you know I can't quite
remember I don't think I didn't know it
doesn't sound right
then he's asked why he stated Epstein's
house after Epstein was very publicly
convicted for child sex crimes and you
know Prince Andrews answer he's just too
damn honourable but you were staying at
the house just convicted sex offender it
was a convenient place to stay there's I
mean I mean I've gone through this in my
mind so many times at the end of the day
with the benefit of all the hindsight
that one could have it was definitely
the wrong thing to do but at the time I
felt it was it was the honorable and
right thing to do and I admit fully that
that my judgment was probably colored by
my tendency to be too honorable but
that's just the way it is oh my gosh
you've got to be kidding me
you do year there are two excuses in
here he said they said why did you stay
at that convicted sex offenders child
sex abusers house well you know it was
very convenient because the Prince a
British Prince cannot afford a hotel
room who was so convenient you know it
was much closer to the airport than the
Marriott so I just felt I would stay
there I am pretty sure the prince can
stay wherever he wants in the whole
world I think he's got other friends I
think he can go to other private
residences pretty sure he could stay at
the top floor of the Ritz whenever he
wants to says the first excuse and then
the second one the second one is so
great he stayed with the convicted sex
offender because he's too honorable this
is the excuse you hear like in job
interviews I'll say
your worst quality and then when it's a
kid right at a school say you know I
think my worst quality is probably I'd
say I probably I care too much you know
I just work too hard and so it's really
sometimes it's really hard for me to
separate my my work life from my
professional life because I just give
too much to the company that's my
problem
I'm too good I'm too good Prince Andrews
what I I guess it's because Prince
Andrew has never had a job and the way
we think of jobs he's never had a job
interview that's for sure and so he
gives this absurd line with a straight
face instead of just if he just came out
and said yeah he was a friend of mine
obviously I was associating with a
disreputable character and I shouldn't
have stayed with him okay it's not a
satisfying excuse but at least it's you
can believe it and then finally Prince
Andrew gets caught in a lie he's asked
wait hold on a second we see pictures of
you holding the bare midriff of these
underage girls with Jeffrey Epstein at
Jeffrey Epstein a place well doesn't
that seem to be incriminating and he
said it couldn't have been me that the
accounts that these girls are describing
where we had sweaty sex can't be real
because I can't sweat that's what he
said
ureas she described dancing with you and
you profusely sweating and that she went
on to have possibly there's a slight
problem with with with with with the
sweating because I have a peculiar
medical condition which is that I don't
sweat or I didn't sweat at the time and
that was machine yes
I didn't sweat at the time because I had
suffered what I would describe as an
overdose of adrenaline in the Falklands
War when I was shot at and I simply it
was it was it was almost impossible for
me to sweat and it's only because I have
done a number of things in the recent
past that I'm starting to be able to do
that again so I'm afraid to say that
that there's a medical condition that
says that it didn't do it so therefore
oh my god dude why on earth is
PR guy is his publicist quit when Prince
Andrew agreed to do this interview he
should have quit long before that I mean
he's still gonna get some blame here one
earth prepared him for this interview
because photos have since come out
showing Prince Andrew at parties
surrounded by women sweating I couldn't
have had sex with these girls because
they said that I was sweaty and I can't
sweat because I was shot at during the
Falklands War what very bad gas bagger
II and it's it's important to see this
because the Royals are always kind of a
kooky family and it's especially the
ones who are a little more degenerate
than the Queen who is really just a
model of grace but when you watch them
just fall apart under this kind of
scrutiny you look back at our own
politicians and it gives you a certain
respect for them because they're so
shameless and they're so practiced and
they're so skilled at it but they're
just as full of it and occasionally just
a little evidence of that hot air
squeaks out of them such as Eric's whoa
well on live television it's the same
sort of gas baggie and what they do is
they Gaslight us I know these are puns
I'm actually not even doing that
intentionally Natalie's not anymore
these this gas lighting is with so
offensive to us because these people
Prince Andrew I guess most ridiculously
but Pelosi swore well Chris Murphy these
guys go on television and they tell us
not to believe our own lying eyes they
tell us not to believe our own lying
ears they're trying to force a narrative
on us that is obviously untrue and
people really don't like being lied to
I've found if you're just straight with
people they appreciate that you know
President Trump during the 2016 election
more or less came out and said yeah here
all my flaws okay I've never pretended
to be a saint but here's what I'll do
for you here's what I'm promising and I
won't lie to you I'll talk straight to
you and generally speaking by
politicians standards he has done that
if Democrats think that they were gonna
win in 2020 and that is what all of this
circus about impeachment is about if
they think that
are going to be able to win in 2020 by
continuing to push a false narrative by
continuing to tell the American people
not to believe they're lying
eyes and ears then they're going to lose
and it doesn't matter how many
candidates are in the race more
candidates are entering the race even
now because Deval Patrick entered the
race we haven't even talked about that
because who cares but you know they had
25 candidates that wasn't even enough
because they are not dealing with any
relation to reality here that is not
going to serve them in 2020 and if they
want to have any chance any chance in
hell they've got to deflate themselves
expel the hot air presumably or
preferably off-camera and deal with the
reality of the political situation I'm
not holding my breath
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a caved to the
left after years and years of defending
their Christian values you know they're
closed on Sunday as Kanye West recently
wrapped they would donate to a number of
Christian charities but you know really
unobjectionable charities like the
Salvation Army they caught a lot of
flack from this for this from the left
because the left hates Christianity so
the left doesn't want them to donate to
Christian charities like the Salvation
Army and they say that it's because the
Salvation Army discriminates against
homosexuals or something but that isn't
true at all
anyway after years and years of this
chick-fil-a has caved to the left and I
think I've I'm the only person who's a
little bit relieved to hear this news
because for years I have had to pretend
that I really like chick-fil-a
sandwiches I don't I don't really like
any fast-food chicken sandwich fast food
hamburgers are much better than fast
food chicken sandwiches but I've had to
pretend me as chick-fil-a has been such
a good company and such a symbol of
conservative resistance to leftist
cultural tyranny and now they're not
here's what chick-fil-a said quote as
chick-fil-a expands globally and into
more liberal parts of the US the chicken
Shan plans to change which charities it
donates to after years of bad press and
protests from the LGBT community or this
is this is from a report obviously so
beginning next year chick-fil-a
we'll move away from its current
philanthropic structure after donating
to more than 300 charitable
organizations this year the Atlanta food
chain will instead focus on three
initiatives with one accompanying
charity each education homelessness and
hunger so they've gotten all this bad
press they're expanding their business
and they don't want any more bad press a
couple things to learn here one
chick-fil-a is going to learn this if
they haven't learned this all wet ready
for most companies with a few notable
exceptions if you get woke you go broke
if you kowtow to the leftist mob you
will collapse look at Dick's Sporting
Goods takes guns out of their their
sales drop tremendously that's going to
happen to chick-fil-a here they're
basically saying hey all of our
conservative supporters we don't care
about you we're going to try to get
forgiveness from the woke mob you by the
way you're never gonna get forgiveness
from the woke mob anyway they're just
gonna ask for more and more and more but
the other thing that this shows you
which is important in conservative
debates right now is perfectly free
markets perfectly economic views of
politics are insufficient because let's
say that chick-fil-a's decision to stop
donating to the Salvation Army - more or
less apologize for being Christian let's
say that that decision increases the
bottom line by 5% I don't know I'm just
pulling a number out of thin air let's
say that that were to happen it would
still be bad it would be bad for the
culture we would have a better culture
if businesses made five percent less but
actually stood for some values actually
helped to maintain our American culture
and at least pay lip service to the
faith that founded our civilization that
would be better and that's not what's
happening here
because chick-fil-a is selling out to
Mammon seek you first the kingdom of
Mammon I guess is what they're saying
Salvation Army has issued a statement
because their Salvation Army is losing
donations from chick-fil-a the
Fellowship of Christian Athletes and the
Paul Anderson youth home here's what
Salvation Army had to say quote
were saddened to learn that a corporate
partner has felt it necessary to divert
funding to other hunger education and
homeless organizations areas in which
the Salvation Army as the largest social
services provider in the world is
already fully committed we serve more
than 23 million individuals a year
including those in the lgbtq+ community
in fact we believe we are the largest
provider of poverty relief to the lgbtq+
population when misinformation is
perpetuated with that fact our ability
to serve those in need regardless of
sexual orientation gender identity
religion or any other factor is at risk
we urge the public to seek the truth
before rushing to ill informed judgment
and greatly appreciate those partners
and donors who ensure that anyone who
needs our help feel safe and comfortable
to come through our doors very good
statement I've always liked the
Salvation Army I was like to put a buck
or two in their their pots when they're
ringing the bells at Christmastime
absolutely pathetic stuff you're from
chick-fil-a absolutely pathetic stuff
what is going to be the effect of this
of this LGBTQ leftist activism is that
this charity is going to get a lot less
money they're gonna be able to do a lot
less good but it doesn't matter they
don't care about doing good they just
want to virtue signal and what is the
virtue that they're sending sure doesn't
look like a virtue to me chick-fil-a is
not the only company doing it sprite
right now lemon-lime soda is testing out
an advertisement in Argentina and I
watch this advertisement a couple times
I don't see anywhere in the
advertisement where they mention sprite
soda here it is
for those who can't see who are just
listening on describe the scene you've
got a mother painting makeup unto her
transvestite son
[Music]
throughout the whole commercial you've
got these you know a mother binding the
breasts of her young
I guess transgender child so a young
young girl who wants to be a boy the
mother is binding the breasts up so that
the girl can more closely resemble a boy
throughout the rest of it you see
parents coming out and just affirming
the gender identity of their child
regardless of that child's actual
biological sex now one thing that's
missing from the commercial I'm not
casting aspersions on this kind of
bizarre commercial at least not yet one
thing that's missing is sprite where's
the product where's the soda you're not
selling this at all
what you're selling is this really weird
ideology where you're forcing gender
ideology on children on actual children
in this case I don't care if somehow
this increases sprites bottom line by
five percent I don't think it will but
even if it did I don't care I want a
good culture
I want a culture where we can say hey
forcing sex and gender ideology on
ten-year-olds as a bad idea I want a
culture where we can say hey if you want
to donate to the most famous
homelessness charity in America that's
been around for a very very long time
and has always done great work you can
do that without being called a bigot I
want to live in that culture I want to
live in a culture where the CEO of a
company can be a Christian and not
threaten his entire corporation over it
and not be forced to kowtow to a small
but vociferous leftist mob Andrew
Breitbart very famously said politics is
downstream of culture that's true
culture is also downstream of politics
okay and there are policies in this
country that are encouraging this sort
of culture policies which always
privilege for instance atheism over the
religion that founded our country
Christianity policies which
sex and gender ideology on children in
schools these these sort of policies are
are affecting our culture and we when we
think about politics we want as much
economic freedom as is possible economic
freedom is a great thing
allowing people to do what they want
with their own property in their own
labor and their own money we also want a
culture because you can have all the
money in the world but if you don't have
a coherent society all that money isn't
gonna buy you very much before we go I
have to get to this a woman a mother of
three in New Zealand is is now saying
she's faced death threats because she
shared pictures from hunting trips which
show her carrying animals carcasses away
after a hunt she's gotten death threats
for this for posting it on social media
I think this would be fine if she wanted
to take the animals and cut off the
heads and put him on the wall I think
this would be fine if she just wanted to
leave the animals and let other animals
eat them but what she's actually doing
is killing the animals and then eating
them herself she's feeding her family
with these animals that she's eating or
that she's hunting rather and part of
the reason she's doing this is because
she thinks it's more sustainable it's
better for the environment and it's
better for the health of her family than
using a factory farm so the people who
are environmentalists who are terrified
about global warming should actually
support what this woman is doing because
it's really talking about farm-to-table
she's going out killing her own food and
eating it takes that so much of the
environmental impact of factory farming
but it doesn't matter because people
want to virtual virtue signal without
any sense of virtue I gave a speech last
night at the University of Kentucky go
check it out the speech is online it's
called babies or not people it was a lot
of fun the Q&A got pretty feisty too
because we had some I think that people
are called gropers they're critics of
conservatives from the right who showed
up also and we had a fun Q&A with them
so go check that out but the thrust of
the speech was that in America today if
you disturb the nest of a bald eagle
you'll be fined a quarter million
dollars and go to jail for two years but
if you kill a human baby at any stage of
development practically
you'll be applauded as a great defender
of freedom I mean if you kill a baby
after birth in Virginia the governor of
Virginia says that's perfectly fine that
is a bizarre moral system right now
speaking at the 20th World Congress of
the International Association of penal
law in Rome the Pope Pope Francis said
quote we have to introduce we're
thinking about it too the Catechism of
the Catholic Church the sin against
ecology the ecological sin against our
common home because a duty is at stake
far be it for me to ever criticize the
Pope but consider this a filial
correction very respectfully there's no
such thing as a sin against ecology you
cannot sin against ecology sin can only
be against God and those made in the
image of God we are the stewards of
creation now of course we can abuse
those things and to abuse creation is a
transgression but sins can only be
committed against people we are in a
culture now I mean it's why I bring up
the chick-fil-a example it's why I bring
up the extreme of that the sprite
example we are in a culture that is
getting things not just a little off
kilter but actually completely backwards
we're now living in a culture where
people who hunt animals for their own
food are getting death threats but
people who kill babies are being
celebrated as heroes that is a that is a
shameless culture that is a culture full
of hot air
that is a gas bag culture that is
telling you not to believe the reality
that we're all seeing in front of you
but instead to believe the narrative and
unfortunately at least on the cultural
level and on the religious level some
people a lot of people have gone along
with that narrative don't do it put a
little pin prick in it deflate that gas
bag narrative and let's all come back to
reality that's our show on Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show if
you missed the speech lines and I go
check it out babies are not people you
can find that on The Daily wire YouTube
channel and then I will see you tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show the evidence
is uncontradicted that the president
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help him cheat an election the
Michael Knowles show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director
Pavel why douse key edited by Danny
D'Amico audio is mixed by Mike gore
Amina hair and makeup is by Jessa all
Vera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]